قال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان انه يتطلع لتوسيع قاعده
التوافق السياسي حتى يمهد الطريق لخطوات
اخرى اكثر اهميه
مواطنين
وبلادنا تستشرف مرحله جديده لتطلع فيها
لتوسيع قاعده التوافق والسياسي حتى يوم
احد الطريق لخطوات اخرى مهمه
القضايا الجوهريه التي حددها الاتفاق
الايطالي لنضع جميعا ومعايير تشكيل
الحكومه وبرامج الانتقال التي تهيئ البلاد
للانتخابات العامه لنهايه الفتره
الانتقاليه
وجدد البرهان التزام المؤسسه العسكريه
بالخروجي نهائيا من العمليه السياسيه كما
حذر من ما سماه اقصاء الاخرين وتقزيم
دورهم وعدم الاستماع الى مطالبهم وفرض
الوصايا من فئات المحدده من قطاعات الشعب
لقطعناه في يوليو من هذا العام لخروج
المؤسسه العسكريه نهائيا من العمليه
السياسيه مع التزامنا بحمايه الفتره
الانتقاليه استجابه للمطالب السوريه
وضرورات الانتقال كما نرجوا ان يتم تكوين
الحكومه الانتقاليه من الكفاءات الوطنيه
المستغله وتكون برامجها الاساسيه ايجاد
حلول عاجله للمشاكل الاقتصاديه والعمل على
استكمال بناء السلام وتحقيق الامن
والاستغرار والتهيئه البلاد للانتخابات مع
توحيد اللحم والوطنيه